okay the first thing I want to say no no
the first thing I want to say is okay
what pick a shade man pick a shade with
that like a shitty Crayola node why are
you dressed like Chris Gaines tan you
know when Garth Brooks wears the time
for color church it'll be green here on
one side and the black on one side you
doing it I don't mean to open up the
[ __ ] I don't mean to open up the show
with a huge move like that but no people
made eye knockings what we're just hit
that because it's you look like an actor
from American Pie dude holder's dude it
looks you got that for free
that's such as that's such a [ __ ] I
did get it for free
look man dude that's such a hoodie you'd
wear for free would not buy that you
never go out that [ __ ] shades off
right now know why I gotta wear these
dude mmm futures too bright otherwise I
wouldn't have them on but mmm futures no
right did you see what I did his bright
you see the picture I tweeted the
Instagram yeah about the black and white
photo the one I'm you said yeah that he
yeah bro oh you know what's weird is
that is that you you posted it only
hours after he posted it not days after
he posted well I that's why there's a
new episode of fighter in the kid right
when it comes out hey there's a new
episode of fighter in the kid six days
ago and there's already a new episode
yeah cuz I like to create a lag don't do
that hey Chris that is the Maury can I
ask Chris the serious question yeah yeah
hey Chris so do you think Brian fondled
Chuck Liddell's balls last line the
groom
oh he just power ball dude when we live
up dude we were hanging out having a
good time a silly [ __ ] loosey goose
time yeah Chuck Liddell walks in this
guy is a transformer and transformed
into a [ __ ] dick
yeah oh no oh everyone turns into a
fighter jet but me I turn into a [ __ ] no
no no listen hold on like talking about
training and sparring do you know as
soon as you like then you go oh my god
you don't look a day over 25 oh don't go
like this huh look yeah he looks good
but huh
he looks good but except for huh
what are you doing dude you can do what
you want it's free conch don't promote
your shirt it's freaking it's not
congratulations we're here you're
welcome because I have a podcast now
subscribe to my podcast congratulations
and I want you to unsubscribe not
anything Brian podcast is not I'm not
saying anything
okay well it's true no Chris the future
is bright but my girls are [ __ ] take
them off
now you get to see inside hey you don't
there's not a lot of depth bro come on
what are you tired you if I drew a
[ __ ] picture of your brain coffee
hanging out and with my sidekicks and
chicks and chicks man lazy lazy do all I
think you're a book if we're all books
Eric Chris is a comic oh yeah is that
fair well dude Connor you look so
graphic novel yeah okay dude I mean The
Watchmen okay no it's my hero what do
you think seriously what do you think
you would be the sloth no do you know
what I have a superpower what I can open
up doors without even touching now at
the grocery store
Oh Brian didn't get the job how do you
do that he says I do it because my fans
open the doors for me
do
your fans don't travel with you around
that you've seen that uh you know what
my fans are there they and I'm not
trying to be a dick to you and no no
listen every time you say that it's dead
no no but let me just explain what my
fans are and it's no big deal and I
don't give a [ __ ] I don't even want I
didn't want to say this out loud because
I don't care but I'll say it just for
argument's sake let's have a
conversation
so my fans our fans what we would call
fans in life right now hold on it's just
that there's there's cuz I'm always
evolving always like challenging
argument this guy teaches me teaches and
then you your fans are as we know and
again who cares who cares what your fans
are some are not yet in high school and
others are in high school right so great
they also hear themselves as babies they
come you know in our fan bases what T
fat cake hey [ __ ] hey hey hey Chris butt
chin disappeared when he went like that
I'm not yeah I can't wow you're just no
chill row bro bro you human bird we are
uh we are [ __ ] twenty we are thirty
we are 40 or 50 my god your babies dude
what [ __ ] why do you pay this because
dude [ __ ] this alpha secretly beta [ __ ]
bro I got it all figured out
I'll do what I want and it'll be fine
and because your buddy everyone's fight
oh we're gonna do [ __ ] you know what
I mean no you're not saying anything
[ __ ] you know what I mean how about
this man see what this man what number
one guest on fighter in the kid oh dude
any people say forget though okay will
sasso michael rapaport yeah make way for
[ __ ] free conch you got this out
that's hey you showed me your body
yesterday pretty damn good right no I
don't think so what okay
did you see the [ __ ] region I didn't you
all I saw his dick in the bathroom and
leaned over and saw it no but you got to
see it when I was ten Hut no it's not he
swung it around like a road or tassel no
I don't wash my hands after I piss you I
don't either who does weird it's my dick
I wash before I touch my exactly and I
don't touch the door I do elbow it yeah
it is impressive because the legend of
Chris D'Elia let's be honest the legend
started on the find the kid no because
Ari Shaffir dick about the Comedy Store
listen to me then brian chimed in about
you dick I'm Brian got all the shot on
it fine it's fine
no it's fine you heard about it though
the masses yeah but but what what what
sucks is don't get your fit well when I
get why I got a Fitbit when I get when I
when I when I get a boner I faint a lot
because of the bad blood hey lose a lot
of blood oh yeah I just oh you are okay
sundial they go like no oh yeah no can I
ask you a question maybe so you are are
you anemic dude not because I might
color you have you know what it is no
it's alabaster why it's not it's
porcelain white yeah is what it is in it
but it's it's very a lot of kings and
queens are that because they don't go
because of the workers go outside so you
don't you don't really see the Sun don't
work it's good have you had your vitamin
D check no I go I went I was in the Sun
today you live on pancakes bro
what do you bro you you can finish your
pancakes last night now I only have
what's that pancakes yeah I had a one
but we're okay swingers they got nice
buttermilk pancakes shut up who says
buttermilk pancakes just say pancakes
yeah well no pain you yes unless they're
like banana nut pancakes guy says border
berry but standard yeah pancakes day oh
my god I like when they say when they
say buttermilk it turns me it gets me
going like now you go to swingers every
night right a lot yeah and you you find
a corner and you eat I don't need people
to be
oh yeah dude I don't care I'm kidding no
but that is a bastard you did shut down
Starbucks
my nephew called me and said hey Chris
D'Elia just walked in to Massa eat say
and he's alone and I went yeah of course
he's alone cuz he's a weird went in by
you ate dinner by yourself and they go
hey bro look at me you serial killer or
or you loser
no since one of the sushi bro did you
have some soup and rice
what do you don't eat raw fish yes you
do do you do what are you saying man did
you order a mustard turkey sandwich
that's what you eat you ate sushi why
were you there by yourself dude I
[ __ ] you know what I do what not only
do i do i not invite anyone i send a
text out and i say I'm getting sushi
no one's invited and then I go by myself
you know why dude because I [ __ ] up
here bro hey I got his [ __ ] blast you
do that have a blast I have a blast dude
I just think anything I want nobody's
there to [ __ ] be like oh but also
[ __ ] them dude I just chill you're right
hanging out I have a good time and I eat
sushi and I go like this and I think
about stuff what do you talk about lash
to do what do you think about like
seriously um I think about like the
people around me and if someone Falls
and that would be funny or like I'll
think about something I could talk about
on stage or I think about my mom or I
worry about you don't worry really why
would I worry why would I worry you
don't worry dude
no you don't wake up with like anxiety
sometimes yeah sometimes I do I felt
what I don't know and then I and then I
go like this what am i anxious about and
I go it is all of you anxious that it's
gonna end by some weird thing as in like
an accident or I think about weird [ __ ]
yeah I guess so sure the egg dragons are
you do you you know you have worried you
what yeah you worry you're like me you
uh no I'm not like you
no no no you were yeah you get like a
speck you think you have stage 5 cancer
why don't worry that's why I worry more
about like um like how long will I keep
still like how many how they really keep
coming up with material like you might
gonna like next month I'm like
and then the roads over that happens all
the time when I specially after you
shoot a special then you go I gotta
start all over again yeah am I gonna and
how am I gonna do cuz you know I don't
remember coming up with the [ __ ] I know
no be either you ever do a bit decided
me interrupt you you ever do a bit and
then he like well how the [ __ ] did I
come up yes
did someone help me with that's what I
mean where did I get that from right and
how many co new [ __ ] exactly like that's
what I mean at that do you feel away
yeah well my last one of my last tour I
was doing that act for like a year and a
half two years and then afterwards I was
like what the [ __ ] do I do and then I
just started but I just that's why I
constantly book shows and go on stage
because I'm like oh I'll keep I'm not
gonna do the old [ __ ] yeah and then I'll
just do that I'll do new [ __ ] yeah you
know even if it's not good and then it
pretty soon it kind of like takes a life
yeah yeah warms on its own yeah mm-hmm
yes that is interesting like you just
kind of have to trust that it's gonna
happen and Anna and it's true you just
keep doing it until some do you have any
idea you have Netflix doesn't let you
know how your special did man I'm fine I
just know from like tweets and hilarious
they can get kind of gauge right from I
mean well you because your your
Twitter's and social medias gonna be
more your fans you know I'm saying the
bottom so you like oh it's great but
yeah but getting new ones that people
say oh I don't know who you were or or
or you can tell because of your crowds
get bigger you know that makes sense
yeah for sure that's the big thing
because specials everything these days
right well yeah I mean yeah yeah and as
you look at it cuz like I watched sign
fields new special if you watch it I
didn't say [ __ ] brilliant and it's
it's all material yeah yeah I heard
prove that sounds like a documentary to
know it's like stand up but and just go
it shows like a quick clip of his
childhood and then goes back I guess it
shows like old stuff but it's also old
materialist to show that it stood up
over time and still you know this is
really but but I watched that and then
in the queue it goes Dave Chappelle bill
burr Chris D'Elia
that's where Netflix has just been
alright yeah oh you watched Chris Rock
check out Chris D'Elia and when you get
in that cuz how how big is Dave
Chappelle yes so they oh that's
hilarious
God he's similar that and they watch
that I also think I [ __ ] up my those
I didn't I don't know [ __ ] up the
right word but when I this one this new
one that came out man on fire which is
on Netflix I just said that all right
man I know you watch it yeah but don't
so nobody know I didn't actually even
notice I was looking at the camera
oh you but okay it's a wild flicks yeah
thank you very much all right stream it
doesn't matter but and that one no I'm
the incorrigible which is the one that
was my second one which is right before
man on fire on Netflix you can I think I
started slow I can I put all the good
[ __ ] at the end yeah you know oh and
people have the attention yeah they
don't I'll watch comics on there yeah
it's like yeah I'll be 20 minutes and
I'm like this is yeah they don't so I so
I open man on fire with you give this
stuff that I thought was the the
hardest-hitting [ __ ] that's that's smart
but that's also why Netflix it's just
people's attention span yeah but that's
why they're leaning they're doing a lot
more 30 minutes yeah not not even to
mention my incorrigible was like an hour
and 20 minutes over over yeah about an
hour too long for me yeah but really and
the man afar is 64 minutes or something
like that
no that's not what they're doing okay no
I know you know what actually they are
doing that because that's the Dead
Rising they're ghosts because they want
to see it to Chris so that when you do a
Netflix specials you sign a multi like
term deal or we don't sign a multi we
sign maybe you could send a Multi multi
oh you said multi so I don't think thing
hey bro PCP no John that's so not that's
so [ __ ] what that one word yeah he
never got he'll know it's certain words
oh he's working it I'll speak for a
living I don't I didn't but I guess you
could but I don't think they do that
though yeah I don't think they never I
never was never an option for me
so it's just one it so if it doesn't do
well just one and done that I write well
you know I'm saying I'd yeah if it
doesn't do well it's kind of a weird
format because you do one yeah I think
you just do your next one with whoever
grant
yeah biggest show in town you just got
guy I'm gonna go over here now yeah I
mean I don't know I mean I'm [ __ ] no
I you do you know I have two on there so
it's good to have I think it's good to
have two on there and so guys have four
or five on there I guess all efflux what
doesn't burn a fill where her probably
mmm Logan has what three two on there
hmm
so I don't know but uh I don't know if
Iowa like before Netflix became what
happen I always thought it was I was
like I'll be cool to do one like I did
one for Comedy Central did and then the
next one different Netflix was like I
wonder where I'll do the next one but
the Netflix got so big that I was like
oh you just got be on you have to
compete and like I don't know if like
although you know if hula would do him
but they don't do him I would be willing
to bet they start to get into it I heard
they were going to but that was like a
year and a half yesterday would cuz they
just won all those Emmys they beat
Netflix like destroyed they want you and
these in any network through and it's
Hulu so I would assume and then Amazon
Facebook's doing what time what time 14
I know a lot of times you so much to do
it you know what do you know what I feel
like you you you would know this - I
feel like Chris is starting to get more
and more into act and I feel like it
back then takes up you done with comics
am surprised you're not doing more
acting do you actually feel that way
I love stand-up no because you're not
you are very thank you
you know I just slip in and out of
characters and it's like he ever hit
team and people don't even realize any
sort of them cockney thing that's all
you know came to me you know I mean no
he's just jumped into it it's lawyer
it's not sploosh like you know when you
go into you know when you're lying in
out like near a pool and then all of a
sudden you're like I'm gonna get in
there sploosh that's what is a character
right you know not bad at all and you're
from the east of London or all over an
army brat really you did a movie ops
again you can't see what the movie is
well no it was called life in a year I
don't know if I'm allowed to say what
what I played though really yeah we
don't know I almost want to see it are
you proud of it do you think I think so
I have no idea
cry like do it okay doing them okay
I don't know you know what I mean you
have to go overboard thank you you have
to overboard at crying most people think
subtlety is oh really apologize I'm a
drug lord and apologize you know I mean
like that ah yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] dude
right right cuz I was gonna kill you I
know and then I I felt pity yeah guys
dude because I would take acting classes
I mean ups you grew up in the business
he took a shame to voice his voice and
danced I didn't take dance I know it was
[ __ ] well tell but you took you took
voice does this answer your question
remember when you and I tried to sing
serious yeah yeah and we started
laughing Brian does that Brian likes to
relive the glory days all he has he
doesn't have bright future that's not
true you've got a checkered past well
that's [ __ ] true in a bad way I've
got kids I don't know about and if I
find out I'll ignore the many ways yeah
cuz I'm selfish [ __ ] selfish hey if
we unselfish who are we talking to we're
brand it oh we had my party with Rogen
were talking about that time when you
really thought you could sing like Brian
was he did like what cough they're the
Comedy Jam thing you know we're
comedians see oh yeah goddamn comedy I
mean if I wanted to I could be this
thing dude all right
I mean obviously I could but a little
bit like yours a little bit yeah I mean
I was Q I know how hard it is when you
hear like skylar astin you're like I
know forget it yeah lastly he's like
Broadway and he can actually sing but
yeah like there's some guys wear him
like Brian's not bad you know like you
like it was like a 80s rock your singing
mother there's one note to it I guess I
mean I'm still not doing it but you can
kind of get mama you know
I just killed a man like I can do that
yeah I know I know you like Freddie mine
now it's stupid but but but I can talk
about a town oh my god whatever yeah no
but um wait wasn't gonna say [ __ ] that
thing no I don't know but uh oh yeah I
know I hate when I talk about this on my
podcast congratulations subscribe
unsubscribe them and subscribe to mine
and ever and so but they well I'm my mom
thinks I can sing and it bothers me so
much when she legit things yeah she's
like you could have been a singer and it
bothers me so much cuz it's so it's like
when somebody comes up to you and says
oh dude people say I should you stand up
and it's like turn round bye-bye
but parent bands are a little different
like I get this all the time my mom was
just out here she goes I don't
understand why you just don't audition
for the new Batman right right right
right right
well that's yeah parents I know I know I
know man yeah people come up why don't
you do SNL you don't know how it works
oh that's a good idea yeah oh yeah never
thought of that yeah yeah so you are
somebody that could do that yeah you
have you thought about this until hey
bro I don't know that you would be happy
doing that or energy Danna because you'd
have to give up a lot of stuff so it
becomes a problem like you know I'm
saying so you can do so if you do two
one-hour drama okay great
you better love it because you're their
fault you know let me tell you something
I've always said this too like for my
nightmare mmm is to be like the sixth
lead I'll CSI [ __ ] oh my god
why would you ever take that but does
people do way ahead yeah I think we got
something
oh my god you [ __ ] right in your
trailer just like this that my turn
and you can't hug this 19 times I'm
pulling it up right now you're so
[ __ ] right oh dude you know who
always gets that part the funky chick
- here - yeah holster guys yeah or a guy
that belongs in a Verizon commercial yes
can you hear me now that's what that is
Hey Dude take a knife out dude I'm
telling you I did I've done every CSI to
hang myself done every CSI right so
really yeah I mean I guess star and and
in law and order and just I remember
sitting there wall nor do I've done all
I've done I've done an episode of
something yeah you ever on the
honeymooners
were you a mash no no oh no oh although
math should have been fun but you're
you're there and you watch the you watch
the fourth lead and they're lean you
gota dude I would have you're coming in
a suit and you're pointing yeah at
something and then that's it and you're
you're in Valencia you'd have to love
the craft you got yeah there's not even
a craft no there's no good yeah that's a
word pray sometimes you're saying a
bunch of words that you don't even know
what that dude if you're playing a
doctor or a lawyer
oh well that's the other thing so Grey's
Anatomy er well what they would have to
be is in the background of every show oh
yeah yeah you're in the background when
they was your lane and you're one of
those series regulars you sit in the
background for a long time doing
business oh the worst you passing a
scalpel back in Thea now I was with so
Nick Nolte say with Nick Nolte
hall-of-famer I mean Nick Nolte an 1890s
was big and I did warrior with him and
we were in the we were basically in the
background of a scene that I'm with I'm
with him and I'm like and we had to sit
there for wit stand and he was 70 at the
time we had to stand did he complain no
weird Stan for 11 hours and I said to
him as a pro how do you do this he goes
part of the job it's it was like yeah
it's what house he made now who do
people that don't do that or
Pacino and De Niro they go they have
standing there like now yeah well but
here's the thing do don't have to do it
the standard you do that's where you
make the money but like that's where
they make the money rather but when
you're doing like we do stand-up when
you get a taste of that oh my god and
when you can make money doing stand-up
or get it oh I'd rather do that than
stand around in a lab coat I
this is what I always say it ruins in
some ways you can ruin your acting yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but then why
why do so many stand-ups who they get so
much exposure then they get movies and
then they kind of just ditched the
stand-up they do because you're a lot
easy do you know it's honestly I
honestly think it's a it's a lot easier
stand up no do all Act yeah yeah I think
people get lazy and I feel like they've
done it like dude like they've done it
you do three four specials and you're
like all right you know I get that and
it's not so hard
it sounds like time up with new [ __ ]
yeah especially especially if you're
like a superstar and you have to take
the next link you know you didn't say no
no no well if you're a super starting
together take you and you get it but you
got to take to the next level right
right there's a lot of pressure so then
some go you know I'm just gonna make
rush hour seven but you're shooting a
page a day and you know a lot it's like
when you're doing a movie like that
you're you're the center of attention
and you like everybody you having fun
you're hanging out yeah yeah yeah yeah
but I don't know man personally I've
never done in a lot of ways I've never
done an acting job let's do it what I
don't want it to be over yeah I love the
Goldbergs I do I really loved it yeah
but you can't wait for it to be over
just said that room under the bus and
you honestly turn on your cast mates and
your crew fortune arrow the Goldbergs is
one my I really haven't don't backtrack
first time I've had a really I just cool
that's cool that's cool but you turned
on your Teamsters oh yeah yeah no no you
did yeah I don't know man but but I'm
surprised is that why you haven't done
I've pursued it as much no I have I I'm
going shot a major move yeah I'm gonna
do interesting parts that I find
interesting that I want to do that are
different for me that are fun but do I
want to play the [ __ ] sixth lead in a
movie that's a comedy where it I think
it's kind of funny when I do what I
think is exactly funny every night
onstage yeah no no but you're a sixth
lead you know hey what dude I don't know
for now anyway whoa wait wait but it's
Saturday Night Live
oh no I love Saturday Night Live I would
[ __ ] love to do it yeah you do it but
I can no try out for it no I I think at
this point you know I don't I don't know
but no no but I I think that Sarah Night
Live is always trying and I think
rightfully so I think this is what makes
it so [ __ ] one of the reasons that
makes it so good is cuz they try to [ __ ]
they try to discover people you know
what I mean - you know and everyone
usually goes on to do some gnarly [ __ ] -
like those guys they just let go like I
see what's the black guy things wha
J Oh Jay Pharoah you see he just has a
show oh yeah yeah white shirt yeah like
they all go on to do cool yeah do people
high audition yes now you would know
better like today that's an it depends
like their biggest seizing their biggest
rating ever was last season they had the
rock on though no but you know what
though honestly uh it depends like I was
talking to Pete Davidson who I love I
think he's [ __ ] hilarious and he's on
SNL and he was like I want to do more
stand-up it's tough with the SNL but I
was like but but and but I was like yeah
but you do stand-up sometimes on the
weekend updates and [ __ ] like that and
and I'm like dude that's gonna get more
exposure than than anything I mean you
look at some of those SNL clips they're
like 5 million views on you that's where
it gets oh yeah do because like now that
Saturday Night Live then let's say they
have a funny skit like name something
the rock playing oh yeah oh something
like that they take that clip and they
upload it digitally and then it gets
like 14 million views the next day it's
like carpool karaoke oh yeah you would
do it the Late Late Night know he'd do
it on there and then it's viral would
see there and then so they let not even
a million let's say yeah 600,000 watch
it at 2:00 in the morning right but the
next morning they would upload social
media or you do yeah 17 million views
he's killing it those guys are [ __ ]
killin outs over time my production
value pay for it Wow
the small production value and you get
that that's amazing yeah but the key to
that is you have to have the connections
to these superstars make it happen huh
so yeah like Justin Bieber Jennifer
Lopez right right right right it's a
great idea but you still yeah yeah and
you guys are stuck with me I'm sorry
guys well don't be sorry man you've been
begging us who are the people who are
the actors that you like like your well
what are the do you have a movie like
movies that you [ __ ]
loved ya oh well no I have a style of
movie that I love watching which are
like think of anything with Michael
Douglas and I'll watch it like anything
real or like that yeah like yeah I love
like a perfect murder game all that [ __ ]
yeah I love those movies those are the
movies that I want to do really yeah
gonna do like I thought you're gonna do
like bridesmaids but well no I wouldn't
some a nurse but no but like I would
love to do something like that but like
it would have to be like on a large
scale which that would be but it's like
yeah but what I'm sure a scalper dude
all of course yes like the three of us
obviously obviously
dude chill man I'm really thirsty and so
really thirsty but I'm super annoyed him
um no but like a birth thirsty bro but
like I get I get like that where I'm
like my level I'm getting like if I'm
getting an offer to do something it's
it's not that obviously it's it's like a
way smaller movie why not and it's like
I don't want to take the time out of the
schedule where I'm lazy I'm surprised
you're not getting those bigger offers
it makes no sense to me
I mean I talked to the last movie I
disconnect I'm sorry between I'm sorry
but between [ __ ] Studios and movie
people and they don't understand what
your presence is stand-up in social
media wise I don't think they're I still
think they're missing it I really do
that while talking to each other this
world yeah I'm a jerk you off here like
your Chuck Liddell last night on Bryan
Callen
well yeah when you get those guys when
they come in the Comedy Store you know
I'm saying like you're over the cow [ __ ]
yeah man like when you walked in one's
like yeah yeah oh cool thanks there's
that guy's like Bryan Callen okay you're
gonna you took the compliment right
right oh I got offered that role that I
did um in for the movie from and that's
a Sony picture I mean that's a huge move
it's a big but it's a drama so I was
like well good on the director from in
the world I think you can do it it's
also a leap of faith because the
character you're playing yeah I mean
make sense when I look at you in a sense
okay yeah like when I heard them like oh
yeah that's Chris yeah yeah actually
Chris I know you're thinking were you
thinking but it's not a hero it's not a
superhero no that's not what they're
thinking yeah they were you'll never
play a superhero really dude
really dude yeah you don't think so dude
yeah I don't mind my [ __ ] striations
say otherwise don't you don't have
strike white zone dude I do have them in
my chest if I say whereas it would be
ridiculous I did [ __ ] dips yesterday
between two chairs and that's not that's
not a brag I know but I did him till I
dropped practically you so you did seven
ignored my kids sitting the chair yeah
they were who have you seen laughs nope
they want absolutely like I was like
move daddy gets worse today yeah I got
work to do and then I send you guys my
workout just to yeah it says don't you
guys get a little cup to comfortable
well you know I could eat your ass way
deadlifting a smartcard it was too heavy
it was too heavy and I don't like 25
don't want me to do that and also I want
you to take that hat off that you send
pictures of us in oh yeah anytime about
my my Johnny Depp hat yeah yeah it'd be
a giant powerhouse don't know I respect
him saying no in your face like that I
like that a lot but I think there's a
lonely incinerator somewhere and I think
that it needs that hat and I agree you
throw that away it's fine you're an
artist okay
PRR day to get you are an artist Lu
sorry I'll never say it again but here's
the deal if you can tell someone's that
artist from here yeah yeah yeah kill
them yeah oh yeah
kill if I had Johnny Depp in the right
now he begged if you're not Johnny Depp
bro you're too big to know that always
the same shoes now you're those guys
need to get a different wardrobe period
don't worry who they are I don't care if
you're I don't care how many awards you
want I don't care how good yard acting
don't wear all that goddamn jewelry
bring boy is that bring up
hurry up Jared level Julie no guards
good so you in the tundra bye I agree
don't wear a scarf when it's breezy
agree agree he's a beautiful Jared
Leto's beautiful
he couldn't rest up like the Joker it
looked like it was just Tuesday for him
bye-bye yeah I know he's a beautiful man
and talented his [ __ ] but you almost got
happy so respected but not him no that's
the wrong argument the argument is don't
wear that right not him what the [ __ ] is
what's wrong with a nice hat he's going
the fifth he's got he's Goldman more has
beautiful gangsters a beautiful dowry
about Capone he wears hats a beautiful
down you don't live six hundred pounds
for reps you're a bold giant bull Giants
are not allowed to wear dainty has quite
a long argument we could Al Capone what
you'd make fun of Al Capone well yours
is out Capone well is Al Capone yeah
that face he either went one of the
other gangsters wear half drive your
metro and artistic in kind of look at
that yes it's tilted to the side he's
arguing about this all wrong so what's
argument Chris don't wear it period why
there's no this guy that guy you were a
ball cap or you wear no hat and maybe
you wear a [ __ ] ski out if it's cold
out agree [ __ ] oh wait [ __ ] no keep
going with your tongue what's wrong with
that yeah that's you know here's what's
wrong with that much that's oh that
hurts too much that's a costume
you know what he's dressed like a funky
aunt yeah see ya
he's dressed like the [ __ ] annoying
single aunt that comes over at that is
so true hey man what do you wear
yeah so true you look like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude I agree with that I'm not
rocking that ridiculous outfit it's fine
I get it he's talented as [ __ ] he's
handsome as [ __ ] I get it
he's rich he figured out our he's Irish
change it he's not rich anymore but he
does every level Jared Leto is killing
it
Jared level actually looks good no he
doesn't wear scarfs are weird [ __ ] yeah
he it's just deep no the thing is where
the works on him but your thing is you
guys know no fashion I know fashion bro
eupl ultra busan I thought oh pants
freak cuts a free concert that at Chris
D'Elia calm I do like your shirts out
shirts on my pocket I do like your
shirts okay thank you
I got the me undies on you guys know
about me on the immunde family hey bro
listen Jack you don't think me on these
called us first ones like we do you
think of Chris on it horrible fashion ya
know do you know what I called you you
think his dick will fit in our box or
transcribe oh thanks oh hey bro you guys
know maybe if you wrapped it around is
wrong loosey goose let me ask you
something
your your podcast congratulations it's
killing it gets it gets not it gets it's
just you talking to the my thousand
downloads ma yeah about a half thousand
no more yeah a little more how many per
episode though not much so much well
that's a number yes general my producer
told me not to share them from I don't
know you just do it on your iPhone just
like this in your house
yeah that's pretty it's on video now if
you guys check it out on YouTube typing
North American jobs in 17 yeah dude but
I know but I'm on my 2018 shift yeah but
you're not I am dude or hang on yeah hey
Kalin how scared was we see the start of
podcast and I didn't know how to do it
but godfathers a podcast and y'know I
didn't say that dude but I [ __ ] did
it
you through no you you have okay well
how many thirsty questions the ask about
podcasting
I'll only say the facts and this is not
really we were standing there and and
don't get upset and then I'm spilling
the beans you threw yourself at our feet
and your face
yeah see and your face was on the ground
it was dirty dude please help please
help me no don't I see you said I didn't
do three or so you three selfie and the
the reverberation of the ground made you
fart a little like that then you go I
helped you TT nice and I slapped you
around a little bit to wake you up and
then I I put you in order did you say
you think you said rise and I rose no it
didn't happen yeah and then you said
20,000 texts I got a text from quote you
know why cuz you don't get back when
need some this especially listen get
your finger out of my face
here's what Chris sent me yesterday he's
usually went to that he went to eat and
I wasn't there I was hanging still at
the store and I get a text and said just
a picture of food what was it Nana Kenny
and I get this text come instantly and
that I didn't answer any cousin I said
instantly no and then I came then as I
was left I got this text hour driving
home you're welcome for everything
mm-hmm well I [ __ ] rocked it dude and
I don't get appreciation I rocked it to
[ __ ] each other's text sides on a
podcast well no because food no because
sometimes you want a show to come to a
screeching halt right but still for that
I'll read some podcast yeah pretends he
knows MMA oh dude if there's one thing I
know it's MMA yeah Bella door bell / la
Tour hey Chris on the Darwin Chuck
Liddell came in and everyone was sucking
them ah dude please we scurried like
[ __ ] roaches with the lights on yeah
did you know he broke in hid behind a
car did you know he was Chuck and tell
Chuck and Oh chuck it down Chippendale
I know what Chuck Liddell is do did you
see a year see him fight yeah I fought
him
I would go Oh for [ __ ] sake
Wow yeah wouldn't go no no oh really
dude
you think so come on no [ __ ] you all
right man you ever been in a fight huh
yeah bro yeah when it's wet street fight
have you ever have you ever rode so on
stage so bad they want to get up and
fight you street fights field fights
because you know you know Jeremiah
Watkins that he does Tony Hinchcliffe
he's that so much he was making fun
someone on kill Tony and the dude got up
and punched him in the face are you
serious yeah wait a bunch him I priced
3-4 months you know how the [ __ ] did I
never hear this yeah
you think I knew he did stand-up right
he was doing sanam and Jeremiah made fun
of him right well you know killed Tony
it's [ __ ] hilarious so weird so funny
it was funny I sure do the show I know I
know I got to get back on that show um
anyone tried sucker punch in that beak
nose or hey dude Wow it's proportion
there I'm six [ __ ] today right now no
one's inviting us to cocaine party the
three of us yeah well you do blah no I
don't do blow would you do I'll be
honest when I first met Chris
everybody's made every drug in the book
everyone I got like can I get six
actually never even smoked why no no
drinks nothing yeah you don't even drink
you know [ __ ] hey what the [ __ ] have
you ever had alcohol in your mouth now
what a [ __ ] you're taking you're a
goody-goody - not again this
conversation okay - oh I don't I don't
ask you our boy chin is on tinder he's
40 is [ __ ] single you got a tinder
master here y'all thinking about gender
I've never been on tinder I know but you
know that you're young enough oh yeah
well he's on tinder and he's not hey ho
yo he's done - whatchu talk food was in
the way of me - or on dude hey these
shoes are white hi
shoes are then why do they shot the
[ __ ] scenes in Game of Thrones
we're [ __ ] Jon Snow is rolling around
the mountains on these shoes and you're
gonna step on him I they were in the way
I apologize I didn't mean step on you
can clean them you forty on tinder forty
on tinder but he's not doing he's not
striking out well what do you say your
forty on tinder I do well yeah that you
probably guys say you're 39 I got
probably changed that's what it's a big
one yeah what sucks is you don't you
seem young but but so if a girl hears 40
it's scary it's not fair it's actually
not fair
even though I don't I never live on my
age you don't lie about your age but
like it sucks because like a 25 year old
girl could see you and be like oh yeah
of course but it says four days like I
know because they don't even look and
it's a great point because things they
put forth they go forty [ __ ] it
all that I said yeah put 27 on it well I
mean you know put between you'll be
between 25 and 40 years alright because
I think when you get 40 you're in a
different brackets Oh Brian God whatever
[ __ ] are you saying sometimes just take
a [ __ ] taxi you're saying what we're
saying only with way too many words and
after we said it Bob sorry like um no oh
like bust in angle yeah no I'm just
swapping yeah Brian doesn't it sounds
like you're gonna come you don't say but
yeah I pisses me off with this Google
[ __ ] when they make it all cute it's
cool could be that I don't do Google and
that's it offer you a free car to a
group but change it hey but what's free
quick Incheon do to get some ladies man
I mean you're no stranger that's good no
no no no just a there there I figured it
out already
that's a huge one because so the way it
works B is on tinder you can do like you
can bail C filters if they go under 30
but I can see in Chen
yeah they're not even [ __ ] seeing him
here's the other problem though and we
get read a lot of emails I have some
Asian friends
say Asian male in America it's the
hardest to get naturally you're mixed
bro
say you're mix you're probably mixed
somewhere you are you from the future
dude what the [ __ ] are you from the
future
by 2018 [ __ ] dude right ha cheers you
guys you guys want me to tell you what
happens yes okay what happens to me and
Bryan in the future truffle no say that
because I'm [ __ ] or I'm busting with
creativity right what they do put the
news out there Brian can you please do
30 minutes that's too long for the
comments don't we don't care we don't
care well no he sees the future ogen was
like hey the crowds kind of tough you
know I was like I went mm-hmm you did
that yeah did you say they were tough
for everybody and I was like that's
really obnoxious to me let me close this
bad boy out actually did have a really
great set last night you really really
did yeah and it bugged me why I want you
to fail I'm just gonna come out and say
it I don't care don't give it you a you
you like when Brian I like when I like
when my friends fail hey Bros me room to
rise literally on you guys standing oh
boy no I'm sorry it sucks it's a real
bad character flaw but it's not changing
I'm 37 that unlearn when you're 30 you
can change your ways bro menu we root
for you mmm thank you
nope I want to stand on you literally
you're me me
no ma'am bad purse you know it's funny
this it's true some no comment to never
admit that or its friends there's some
people like that yeah it was weird man
it's so weird when friends think that
what for the thing about comedy is like
the if you succeed it's better for me it
doesn't take away from your knots a
ceiling a spot you're not stealing a
spot that I can't get now right
oh I'm not stealing your fate like
pharaonic I know you just think about
Netflix you watch Dave Chappelle and
then it suggests Jerry Seinfeld that's
good for Jerry Seinfeld I swear to God I
would eat more than that too with my
that's the mentality my friends well
we're not doing what I stress out yeah
you it breaks my heart if they're like
Oh practical three ticket listeners
really coming save yeah we're gonna
relocate the show to dry when in like
like this weekend in Philly Thursday
Friday Saturday when I when I sell huge
amounts of tickets see there are eight a
comedy club this weekend starting
tomorrow it's gonna be it's gonna be
great yeah it should already be maybe it
is right let me check my phone yep oh
that was Alec you also have your wallet
and it was covering it I have today that
you're there tomorrow you happen no see
Brian also posted last night a video of
us saying hey I'm gonna be at helium oh
yeah
that's all he said but at what time
nobody no he said no I'm saying bad
saying what time did you post at
midnight midnight so that I actually
don't know
no [ __ ] you he's 3 a.m. in Philadelphia
here's the thing - he just said I'm
gonna be at helium he didn't say where
it was so no fear
yeah there's other helium clubs people
don't know what the [ __ ] that means
where would they get the tickets well
and he didn't put the link in it I'll
put
all right today I'm gonna do a view late
for us you're gonna plan it today I'm
gonna do a video for us if somebody goes
and sees you in Philadelphia I want them
to not go no why what do you want to
show ego I'd rather them stay home and
watch my Netflix special no of them what
did he so if my if my if it's empty
there are six people what is your face
gonna be like for my hey Chris you call
me up yeah hey man hey how'd it go
what happened with the show only it's so
annoying I'm so funny like 16 people
were in the audience
you're alright no yeah that's so well
yeah and you know you'll be able to
tomorrow's not selling well either what
are you doing nothing what are you
breathing uh I was I'm cold it's cold
outside
so I mean I hope Saturday's big I hope
so yeah me too oh so Tommy it's not
going to be you know there are people
like that he's good you know they they
sociopaths they do this thing where I'm
this guy used to set fires one of it one
of the things is that this guy would he
would like set a fire at the post office
and he would wait and why us yeah watch
the cast I read another guy and my
friend is a lawyer man I learned one my
friends were who [ __ ] represents this
kid over and over again and his parents
are super wealthy he'll start a fire and
he will then dress up like a fireman
I've seen safe us the origin point of
origin is this book and there and he
will guide traffic away from the fire
and he gets off on it what do you do I
find my friend
yep and my friend gets a call and he's
like well I gotta go represent the [ __ ]
completely gets arrested he's a he's a
pyrometer you
he's crazy heard that about the book
point of origin though where the guy
could was a cut was a was a he could
never make the police force and he so he
became like a fireman but he was on a
really low rung and [ __ ]
or some kind of [ __ ] and he would go
set fires and and go and attend they put
him out and he was this arsonist this
big arson yeah does the books called
point of origin or sounds so lawful know
you saw this really really good right
well this is not this is actually not
that I'm saying the same firefighter on
an Indian Reservation who started this
massive fire recently well recently five
five years ago but you know and they
found out it was him yeah he was a
firefighter yeah it was might be the
same story yeah people are people are
such there are some it's weird code it's
weird it's weird like yeah I don't I
don't know but uh I don't like you okay
so I was watching this thing the other
day I don't know what this kind of makes
me think of this but like they were like
oh oh it was that have you seen the
keepers I have on Netflix yes Jesus
Christ yes
you know so I'll destroy your innocence
yeah this is true confession no not yet
but I'm it's in my thing I saw you guys
are talking about it yeah um when you
guys were together and I have binoculars
outside of your window the guy says like
everybody has a dark secret and you're
asking us to expose our darkest secret
that's what we're that's what we feel
like and and I thought like I don't
really I don't know I don't really have
a dark seat I don't have a dark secret
yeah um yeah I mean in other words no I
have you to [ __ ] me dude you know me you
should both your dark so ya know my dark
secrets do you know I'm saying I don't
have one nope Hey Oh what you know I'm
saying became so like you get like an
Odin I can only crow I just I don't a
dark secret
oh my god you seen dark secret like like
like like you know me you know me as a
guy like you don't [ __ ] like Brian
you kill people or Brian what you know
you don't what's all this animal porn I
see on your [ __ ] you know what you
know yeah yeah yeah like kiddie porn
like you don't have that [ __ ] people do
that [ __ ] of course they do of course oh
you mean like super Oh Chris do you have
any dark no of course not no I don't
have a dungeon no cause I'll do it I
gotta get a dungeon bro that's there
gonna be my next purchase a dungeon
Nicolas Cage [ __ ] like where or it's
like always wet and it's just like
you're here and there's like less steel
in the background look where is that in
the dark
mister lag titers just just um so yeah
that's a lag tights and like all chains
like dark like what do you call them
cubby areas where you're just like what
is and then you look and then you kind
of see like and you see like kind of
eyes like in the back view those eyes
and you look closer they're like oh
they're not eyes but they were on why
would you want that no Chris what are
you doing down there I just have too
much money I need to spend on digging no
yeah just top truck you get me somebody
dig your dungeon and then you're gonna
slay them oh good I did oh dude Hyrum
and that'll be like so thank you the
dungeons done and now for my first
captive and then I go and then I go
Shing and it's already like there it's
hooked up and they go no no and it's the
guy who made the dungeon for me and then
their slave and I laughing for 50
minutes
Wow yeah and then they're like yeah I
could [ __ ] him i I don't care he's not
even though he's not even a sexual thing
it's a power thing I don't want to do if
I know he doesn't want me to you know so
that's why you're doing it and it's not
gay just one of ya
would you tonight say the worst part
about this is I'm not even happy doing
the best part about it Ralph and you tie
and then I and then I and then I take
ice cold ice
I take ice and I tell him it's [ __ ]
hot hot pokers and he doesn't know cuz
when a temperature is so extreme and I
put out you can't tell he goes ah and
then I turn around I go it's just ice I
[ __ ] with your mind oh wow your mind
then you let him go real mind I don't
let him go prisoners of war
you never let him go I don't let him go
right yeah I feed him just just enough
and that I tell him and I tell him I get
all of his information anything he ever
knew I'd get information for what though
I don't know log it fun you log it a log
it and there was a guy in this guy in
Italy who was I guess Iranian not yeah
dude
[ __ ] yeah I respect that [ __ ] now could
you touch your face whatever you want
don't do that 100 pounds on you you're
130
I'm 170 and I'm scrappy as all [ __ ]
get out don't say I'm starburst and I'll
be honest [ __ ] boy ask me how I do
against Brennan ask me how I do be
honest I had to watch it and let's let
this is how I answer all my about what
like I if I say how would you do against
Brennan in a fight how would you do
against Brendan in a fight keep them
busy I don't know what that means
yeah because he'd be with the police
filling out a report busy eating your
ass yeah it sounds dude a new term like
well I say yeah I like it I like it as a
matter of fact it's the rapper's
sometime like cannabis said I can you
know I can't say the n-word but he says
I can eat my ass like you know it's not
it's not a I can't say that in work yeah
that's what the lyric bill market its
nutmeg that's what he says wait I was
gonna say oh this grass this guy this
running guy he was a nice he was a
karate and that teacher and he had these
two like he was the air and he was
eating at a cafe and he met these two
Japanese girl
they were tourists they were really
sweet and he goes you know I teach
martial arts come to my studio and his
apartment apparently was above the
steers name he takes him up and rapes
them and this is real a real fight he
rapes them and they're like these
Japanese girls of what the [ __ ] and then
he he makes them pasta feeds them and
then he said yeah then and it really is
them and I got a lock on the rape they
write to the cops the cops come to his
apartment they go what the [ __ ] he's
eating and they go what the [ __ ] you
know and he goes what and they go you
rape these girls he goes well first of
all first of all I gave them a tour
second of all I gave them my dick
because they don't get dick like this in
Japan and third I fed them pasta what
the [ __ ] are you talking about like he
was outraged
Rob like didn't what I wanted coffee
okay crazy they arrested the [ __ ] out I
could see you do it you becoming that my
kid yeah that would be far sad your
Brian three of us hey you would do it
just yeah we gave that narrative and we
just ask you how many people around here
like you who would do that eating after
a workout yep what I gave them my
essence imagine thinking imagine walking
and then in the middle of [ __ ]
thinking I'm gonna cook these girls
pasta like this that's so funny - man
you're the you miming that so open did
your silent here it is here it's [ __ ]
longer heads here so I'm going this way
I don't bunk or [ __ ] head gate is do
you know space do you know how space
works well no again you don't want to
[ __ ] bonk their heads yeah do oops oh
wow you want a bonk heads when you make
love I hate your hair flip literally
never [ __ ] I've only made love by the
way
ah come on even to all of the hookers
you will on the last show we're talking
about there's a Russian dude that 8:30
p.m. in his wife 30
people kill the pickled hands and [ __ ]
maybe they kill his wife killed
that's real yeah do some current events
speaking of wait how about the [ __ ]
director the horror film director in
Hollywood last year who who [ __ ]
trained his girlfriend of all her blood
what yes oh my god I didn't hear this
come on
what he's a horror film director he got
some a really rich Canada family his
model girlfriend in the family or
Canadian he also Scout he comes from
really rich Canada family pull it up on
Google the [ __ ] guy he's a horror
film director this bring him up he's in
LA this [ __ ] nut and by the way
horror film director killer is one of
the worst thing because I would say this
was one a horrible friend ranger of her
blood and then guess was it is wife
[ __ ] it was his girlfriend the [ __ ]
kills girlfriend he did the perfect
crime cuz you can't Google it uh this
vibes just in it was two days ago
he um it was today zero this [ __ ] he
did it a year ago
Oh [ __ ] [ __ ] um horror writer accused
of imitating novel by murder and
girlfriend okay yeah this guy okay oh
yeah she's not but she was beautiful
look at him look at him this [ __ ]
[ __ ] comes from a really I was right
after he said hung and rage blood is
death my after a lousy torture and
murdering his girlfriend and then
drawing her blood in grisly scenes
reminiscent of one of his own plots
he's like wooden 35 sign of a wealthy
Canadian families three weeks after she
gave birth to their baby daughter hold
up please found her body at the couple's
West Hollywood flat that's next door to
you Kristen yeah after her occasions
mother Chris that they make a welfare
call author arrived discover a
screwdriver who was also the author of
graphic novel had locked himself inside
and barricade the front door with
furniture embedding oh yeah cuz that'll
keep the cops out furniture bedding and
after officers forced their way in they
found Cajun dad for sustained blunt
force trauma to her head
Cajun was tortured and mutilated before
shoots killed all her blood was drained
from her body look at this part libel
was arrested on suspicion of sexual
assault and freed on $100,000 or l69 for
hundred what is hell 69 400 guys that
those are those are pounds I'm know it
says L know there's a bounce okay okay
there's a bounce
it's sad that's [ __ ] an awful man how
about how Hey Dude hey how about how
awful this world is it's so awful and so
that's somebody's childhood it's beyond
what you can imagine what a piece of
[ __ ] well does she got [ __ ] he's a
psycho crazy that's honestly he's gonna
kill those people no that guy yeah yeah
yeah but also he wrote about it the cops
are like will you have wrote about a
feature of serial killer murdering a
couple and handling from naked by their
ankles to drain their blood uh yeah you
know yeah you did it yeah yeah you did
it you that guy's constantly going like
this oh my oh the depravity I don't know
that's that's what I call a dark secret
if you I'd be super well yeah all right
let's go to the yeah chance
sorry rapper b.o.b he started a GoFundMe
page to send a satellite up into the sky
to pretty sister no I don't even it's
not I don't believe that dumb he's he's
not you didn't I don't he's just doing
it for public she's also right your GPS
works on the fact that the yeah this one
what's he say well what up guys
let me see will be able to tell if he's
real if you play it what's up y'all is
flattered Bob here
yeah he's joking don't play me because I
would like to sing one if not multiple
satellites as far into space is a stunt
or interns joke that I can to find the
curve I really I'm looking for the curve
no he's joking no he's not he's been uh
he's been like this for a while I know I
know but no come on no you know it only
raise that's not a real thing you try to
reel these try to read anything boy
Eddie Bravo you really uh
why because they're just I don't know it
gives him an identity they don't really
boy I would this guy do it identity they
day to get to belong to a community it's
so hilarious join a poke ball so you
also got a long talk to it like that
also even if you raise the money it's me
rock
Rock run long too rocky and you know
space travel what well it's all I talk
like the [ __ ] earth being round and
all the mouths yeah yes sir but also the
theory of relativity also a million Inc
in a carpet doesn't he's obviously very
NASA I got a million all right we'll do
it something he's very smart but there
are some smart guys who do do a lot of
reading that do it that's not fair to
say be I don't think so
there are some smart guys that do it
your definition of smarts what well I
think they're just they don't read or
they just know that's not true that's
not true there's some flat earth it'd be
impossible to know there's some guys who
are you can't say they're all impossible
to be educated and can think the earth
is flat let's put it that way I just
don't buy it I disagree I don't mean it
there's no water guys ok but why do they
think the earth is flies no scientists
in the world that would there's no
scientist in the world that would say
the earth is flat none none if we google
right now scientists cuz they do I'm not
I think they're batshit crazy we can't
say they're all stupid or I cannot well
can and I will
I can and I will it's just not true
that's one of his posts hold on hunter
cities in the background works these are
this malaria I can't talk well b.o.b
doesn't count but there's some legit
scientists for whatever reason this is a
joke though this guy's joking yeah well
but he's was a Steen yeah yeah but
nobody's that dumb that's that's over
six I know if we all went to school I
know it's mind-blowing it's mind-blowing
anyway but let's move on let's move on
check this out so it's possible that
we'll be able to figure out if someone
has CTE while they're still living
because of this new study what's CT
brain trauma so Matic traumatic
encephalopathy yeah really
I don't know you know CT is no se brain
trauma and we're good but you know what
it is cuz you have it correct I don't
think he does I definitely did well I'm
joking I don't know if you and I
definitely got knocked around in the
noggin a few times yeah yeah yeah so how
are they gonna find it so after a bunch
of different
people donated their brains they noticed
that one thing happened they all had
elevated levels of CCL 1/1 which is a
biomarker to tell you whether or not you
have brain uh CTE
here's the thing you can tell through
through the way people act their speech
their thought process all right let's
say they go you have stage three out of
four mmm I know
cool what now we don't know but this is
a way when this is found when you were
in the door to treatment I don't know if
every what treatments that's how that's
figured out it's the first stage so
they'll figure that's fair yeah that's
what when I would step in the right
training I don't know if I've talked to
you about this but when you were
training sparring football did you did
you and before any of this made mean
stream did you even think about CTE or
no one did you didn't have had many many
it was - it was never it was too early
but you it's like oh it was like almost
like a guy thing you well know it's like
I got my bell rung they got me - oh I
was like the game you know like when you
sign up for right Wow
it's part of the game that's [ __ ] up
shut up Chris well what the [ __ ]
ngratulations is my pod know I want you
know right now Chris I've never had a
concussion oh dude he wears a [ __ ]
his mom makes him wear a helmet at home
ain't that right
even now she raps your head in towels
even now and Pat's you even now yeah
that's what I'm so jealous she get to
wear hats
you never did support did you I did what
do you mean I did jujitsu for [ __ ] so
long and I did basketball and football
and you just lay down the garden so did
you have you ever actually passed to
anybody's card ever I'm just I think I
get out jiu-jitsu you well well no I can
no you can't don't look at me yeah Ken
don't look at me like that what else you
had two Halloween's coming up and in
this town if you're caught
trick-or-treating over the age of 16 you
can get fined up to $200 that's a fair
point
[ __ ] yeah do it that's the [ __ ] -
dude that's the future that's that's the
future that Bathurst New Brunswick what
the [ __ ] is that but yes you know I can
see nature's when they [ __ ] up things
you know what behavior with you I think
it's a good idea yeah yeah Jim
look at hey dude we're gonna lose is a
Racine trick-or-treating you loser
hey dude go buy can hey what the [ __ ] do
you do for Halloween nobody gets pretty
weird you dress up like a dress-up row
hmm oh well you're welcome
I just was there it has nothing to do
with yeah you saw me out there he know
that were like a good idea
did manicure dude I had a tour out there
and I'm kind of like the Trailblazer
Ibiza but Brendan give credit words do
that's my woman but that's not my god I
guess got you out in their in their
brains listen bro
we showed you the possibility manicured
the target he's often he softened the
landing pad for dude you welcome
Australia by the way they love me know
the Miss awesome dude it's I didn't get
I don't you guys do a podcast that's not
why sorry about cuz I don't do a podcast
I have a cult that's what it is and I'm
starting and I have a cult and we're on
our way
I'm not even doing what Australian no my
cult congratulations
airs every Monday Tuesday do you know
what Monday or Tuesday bro by the way I
keep people on their toes little trivia
you only do it once a week yeah yeah
little trivia on a cult little trivia on
a cola
do you know what almost all cults have
in common they're like a what they
basically talk about the end being near
and that the cult is a way out do you do
that cuz I gotta start doing that yeah
so that's what you do as a cult leader
you should definitely be talking both
great end is near okay okay
and and in fact most most like for
example with Isis they basically
constantly talk about how the end is
near and the Quran is prophesied cannot
become the right side of history okay so
what you need to do my coats gonna be is
create like the fact that the world is
about to end but the only way out is if
you might come baby no no my
cult is gonna be then reborn a baby the
end is yeah that's it
[ __ ] these cults this shit's the cult
bro the end ain't close to near we're
gonna live a long time
they suck that be with me and chill out
will venture to a log cabin and party
dude and by party I mean drink coffee
and all the girl get on say will get on
stage some of us will do some stand-up
and also we get [ __ ] and sucked a lot
hello he's a baby a baby you just got
made into a baby baby I I'm bad with
peer pressure don't put pressure on me
guys I think you're a baby you don't
even know I don't think so you're
breathing heavy you're swallowing she
said it's just that when people look at
me and they put lot of pressure on me I
can I put push tip for me baby
you wanna join you wanna get [ __ ] in
sock
all right you guys can be elders what
else you guys got elders
I'm the elder bone you guys know about
this right oh yes n-c-double-a coaches
and adidas they all like have this
scheme together to pay and bribe to get
these certain students to sign with
their schools and then uh wow these are
the coaches right here that's so wrong
huh no it's not wrong like this is the
law is what happens cuz the n-c-double-a
is so crooked literally everybody's
making money except for the players
right right everyone so who are the
player money you know like and if you
look at any program they all have dark
secret right everyone's doing it just
these morons got caught what would you
do well what if you guys pay the players
you pay those and it would stop a lot of
how much would you pay them and how
would you do that if it flares a star
[ __ ] darling no are would you yeah no
cope with the business plan
I immediately Ryan was very cool right
very cool Brian talked about him
proposed right no dude ric flair claims
he had sex with more than 10,000 women
there's no [ __ ] way I believe why how
many did Wilt Chamberlain say he's 7,000
and Paul so he said done that I don't
want to believe Ric Flair Ron Jeremy's
came out and said that that's impossible
yeah I think if you break it down it's
literally impossible it's like for 1 min
a day ya know Bret break break it down
let me see let me see let me see Ric
Flair for a second let's do the song
let's do the how old is he well how old
is Ric Flair right now 68 68 let's say
you start [ __ ] tier soon he's 20 when
I'm up bring up a young so 21 so he's
been [ __ ] for 40 year 40 I'd say 16
say 16 yeah alright 16 - that's a I'll
do anything right here hey he's got a 40
I just stud he's just I so what are you
so let's get my 40 year run so how do we
do it so how do we do it what do we do
so 40 years so 10,000 what's what's 40
times zero and 65
I already I already don't know how to do
it bright or didn't do this 40 times 3
or 65 is what
13,000 14,000 / on him so then divide
then divided by 10,000 another P 1.46
that's one he's [ __ ] one basically
1/2 people every day of his life
yeah that that's not realistic whoa
unless he had like huge orgies but you
know it's not real not like even we'll
also Ric Flair not Brad Pitt I agree you
know it's not exactly the dine P not
it's not any also it's Ric Flair yeah
yeah he's what Ric Flair don't know what
I don't know back in the 70s there was
probably crazy word hey Brian
oh you still buy you can thank you yes
say that for you basically [ __ ] two
girls a day for every day of your life
since you were 16
hey hey dude you got you gotta do more
you gotta do more than that and not that
so long yeah we're about done huh
nope what else you got chin you shut
your [ __ ] oh huh
how long's your pal Cass and I do an
hour and put plus but oh dude if there's
been a horn 20 minutes dude hey dude let
me tell you something if you're still
listening you rule if you're still
listening you're not a baby
dude go to my podcast and start that we
get Brian still trying to figure out
it's it's yeah Brian 14 if it's 41 days
it's 10,000 days it's not it's not one a
day okay well whatever is not one today
it's it's point four six it would be
yeah it's not that's not cool you did
cool that hey Brett no bread no cool you
did it ten thousand so forty times 365
is 14,000 and changed right oh cool oh
cool
hey we believe you now yeah so he
annexed he had 4,000 days he didn't [ __ ]
oh yeah for a little bit more than 4,000
I don't think so I think that's right
why are you here I don't know let me see
nice there you go
suckers [ __ ]
bully get all my I hate this legit yeah
[ __ ] hate this [ __ ] you Chris [ __ ]
there you go dude no dude it Brian
giving it [ __ ] intimidate you with my
body
ah man Chris suck his dick okay Chris
Jim these are other hooks
wake up spots on my neck cause I have to
perform nice dude you got a duck down
yeah duck tail 50 stacking my fat dick
yeah dude thank god man otherwise you
might have [ __ ] lost bro ID tag my
fat dick hey well your spots over bad
bro maybe why do you have spots all of
you back though it's honestly not that
bad now you don't you only got like two
or three or Missy you Tom Hanks from
Phil W well at least you know I can see
the future yes see oh wow oh my god and
Brian's just a skill I swear to god I
let you get me in that head like I swear
to God I did yeah if I build my neck you
wouldn't done I swear to god I'm not
kidding my head I can see the future I'm
nine I'm not even trying to be hey man I
can see the future you're here yeah hey
your hips oh yeah yeah they go big that
everything goes back hey
I could dude don't be serious about if I
did this you wouldn't have done fine
bull don't be serious I don't give a
[ __ ] even if that is true
don't say it yeah but I could and I and
I went down because my back I had to be
careful why did you attack me I've never
really attacked you bro you know I'm not
again you'll know when I attack you why
did you do that cuz you'll be busy Chris
you see I'll just mind my business yeah
and you know that stupid [ __ ] hoodie
over my just firm what happened what do
you what'd you do I should make the
listeners feel sorry for you
no that's like I'm all telling you my
bro I heard it well why what two weeks
ago what why did you try you in double
underline but boxing playing tennis
[ __ ] doing my hobby [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
you did you did you feel oh should I
pull it or was it like an overtime thing
I [ __ ] like doing what
I don't deadlift you don't know what I
mean did it happen I will okay I heard
it and then I decided to deadlift and I
[ __ ] hurt a dude and then I decide if
it funk demouth the I decided the box
when I wasn't ready again and I heard it
again then why do I do it without Reid
and now I probably just why would you do
that when I'm sitting here enjoying Mike
I got a surge of energy and I don't give
a [ __ ] cuz injuries don't stop me from
claiming what's mine what's your what's
your and you plucked my bump up my
[ __ ] bunny tail and gave you a wedgie
hmm your wife that they do kind of you
score you like me just now go tell your
wife if she's still with you after that
uh-huh
what hey but why he doesn't want why was
your only move to attack my fat spotted
dick because that was what's available
so I take whatever opening I see bro hmm
you have an opening between your legs
which is interesting
no are you saying I have Oh don't insult
me don't feminized me it makes me so mad
and if I get underhooks on you
just goodnight no I've got a defense
mechanism what is it I piss I [ __ ]
piss all over dude
uh and it goes far - are you like a
skunk I piss and it go like you know how
if you piss it would be here I pee and
sore
moreover you squirted them here yeah
squirt in your vagi all right you know
what is there any more chin there's a
few more it's up to you really
I think we're done dude you don't sure
to say one more all right okay all right
so a high school football coach out of
the kindness of his own heart brought in
some school kids that were they had
behavior problems I don't want to see
the future I won't see this done his
wife ended up having sex with one of the
players multiple times the player was
like 16 she's 27 so well she's born in
jail and the husband is actually very
supportive of her she faced it initially
faced here's the whole reason for being
a sign no I get I guarantee she agreed
to three years yeah I guarantee he told
her to do it
Oh what I can't promise use my closet
watching and he was turned on I swear to
God
hey you wish I brought a promise you
wish let's jump asked me to do that I'll
ask me did my buddy Chris dark secrets
are you guys what are the way Chris is
sitting close your legs don't see a
problem with it bro dude it's just the
way it's gonna be man that goddamn
Fitbit watch is driving me nah I like to
keep track of my calories baby yeah what
is it with that terrible one call me
baby it's not a watch you look like data
from Star that's it it's not a watch
it's a way of life and if you're a baby
you understand man
let me see the next one bring it up
she's hot the next one really check this
out
Oh California to become the first state
to ban sales of non rescue animals in
pet shops so no more puppy mill oh cool
oh cool but also give me my [ __ ]
puppy
that's cute little gargoyle I want to
kiss that dog right on his face hey hey
hey guys the dog looks like a brain it's
ugly
see ya he looks like a toad oh it's
squeezing - why is it look easy to jail
cell no it's I know he did time that dog
did time it looks like he did something
bad
yeah like chocolate Oh a little bit
lolly chin talk about my friend you Oh
Brian do it what that's a cute dog come
on look at that [ __ ] thing hold on
hold on out of all the document ah oh
yeah these like the cute ones dude why
do that's it those little dog terrible
you know I think you did it track more
girl dude I hate oh yeah oh oh I like
Jimmy busy oh um I need help I need oh
[ __ ] on it yeah hey bro no you didn't
like I want more I'm an addict what oh
hey you know you have to watch out for
when you got little dogs like that hawks
birds of prey yeah I know dude bro Matt
me Birds and coyotes and even cab come
at me birds don't say cattle eat your
pie oats Wow you say coyote no coyotes
no coyote brother this is my peck with
my PEC I'll move it hey do you only do
bench no what have you ever done any
anything with the food I do all the
stuff with the core man and dude my [ __ ]
is [ __ ] tight oh I set you up at
their gym what gym are you going to now
though that gyms pricing was ridiculous
I won't wear crazy hot chicks like much
was it yeah how much was but with Jimmy
on here now no I do all my [ __ ] I have
all my [ __ ] at home what's that Jim cost
hold on a lot of like 2500 months oh
come on that's kind of legit you should
see it it's an awesome gym I get sucked
off no no that's what it's good yeah
yeah that's not I had a trainer I had a
trainer and the trainer come to the
house yeah and now he does anymore
no not for a while Kim Kardashian was he
was he a real good-looking guy was wow
yeah how did you choose your trainer
bosy yeah busy beauty ever do a female
trainer sure not in a pervy way Brian
sorry
so you had this male trainer come to
your house and just worked out like in
your basement
[ __ ] yeah that's about it you're not
serious about it look at my nuts dude
look at my [ __ ] results well I got
before-and-after pictures that'll make
your head spin whether you look at
exactly this I don't I don't what do you
think of my body when I took my shirt
off just now
I honestly Jeff what are you thoughts
are just what do you wanna do I know
it's a hell it's good because you feel
like a Big Dipper I'd like to see Orion
why does they'd are they distracting now
I can't take my shirt off when I go to
the beach he's got food this podcast is
all over guys well it's over we say it's
I gotta piss
hey dude my five ten thirty well Bryan
time would go here he's going to [ __ ]
Philadelphia Chris comedy club this
Thursday Friday Saturday come see me you
bastards
go see Bryan at helium right yeah that's
Philadelphia
yeah t fat Kade calm for tickets Chris
what the [ __ ] did your podcast
congratulations just caught its butt
dude don't be one of the last people to
get involved in this cult man beware
there when it's the beginning because
limited spots really I mean like what
are we gonna all [ __ ] journey out to
a field no a few select members are so
let's do well Brian's face time we're
trying to rap the podcast that okay
alright now listen up guys Chris you are
not the guest of the year but you did a
good job tonight I am the guest of the
year won't thank you it's up to the fans
and what you know what we're actually
gonna put a poll on the site and let
people vote save yourself the baby so if
the babies want to vote they can vote
alright I'm not even gonna retweet it
how's that that's how good I'm gonna be
they're gonna [ __ ] all your fans are
gonna think that I'll retweet it though
just to show love I don't want to be
more more serious about your appearance
that's fair but I have a carefree like
loosey-goosey attitude I don't like it's
what draws people in I think the show's
over all right this has been a great
juicy Brian
thanks guys I'll be wherever doesn't
matter it's all sold out all right well
this is the fun kid with dilia
we're out